thanks for
the intro i'm seth i work at google now
but uh the work i'm talking about i
actually did uh independent of my work
at google
before i worked at google and this was
actually i did my undergraduate at
stanford so it's always
fun coming back i studied philosophy not
computer science or
electrical engineering and and then i
did my phd
at harvard in economics and i
was kind of lost i think on what to
write about and
not really sure what to do and then i
discovered this tool google trends
online somebody told me about it
i'm like wow this is incredible because
i kind of spent six years
five years learning about data and
learning about all the weaknesses of
data
and learning that a lot of like things
that we thought were
were very well thought out or based on
you know small samples of people
where five percent of people answer the
phone and people lie to these surveys
and all this stuff
i'm like wow google is this incredible
data source
uh i kind of think maybe the most
incredible if you look at people's
google searches maybe
the most incredible data source we've
ever had on the human psyche
uh all the data is anonymous and
aggregate of course
so that's obviously important and kind
of since then i did my whole
dissertation i called essays using
google
data and it was kind of three ways
that we could use google searches to
measure something that's otherwise hard
to measure
so i'll talk about some of that research
now
so google trends uh is this source i
don't some of you might be familiar with
it some of you may not
more and more people are becoming
familiar with it but you can go with it
it's a little addictive if you do go to
it you can kind of play around
and see what people are searching in
different countries in different parts
of the united states through time
etc and one of the things
that you'll immediately find out when
you play around with google trends
is that it correlates very strongly with
kind of what you think or what
it should mean uh so this is searches
that include the word jewish the
percentage of searches that include the
word jewish in different states the
united states
if you know anything about the jewish
population which i'm kind of an expert
on for
for obvious reasons uh is uh it's very
high in new york and actually this has
an r
squared about 88 of the variance in the
jewish population can be explained by
this map
uh what what percent of time people
search for for jewish
uh compare that to mormon search rate uh
very different obviously very very
concentrated in one state
in particular and then a second state
idaho is a little bit more and this r
squared is about 0.99 with the the
mormon population which
is a very concentrate in these areas i
think a few points kind of stand out
uh when you think when you see these
maps uh one of them is i think we talked
about biases and searches i think people
are kind of surprised to think of
searches as
a as a a measure of something it's
a survey we're kind of comfortable
asking somebody are you a mormon are you
jewish
to kind of say from your searches are we
going to measure something it's a little
weird
uh you can think of this is searches
that include the word mormon that also
includes
searches for book of mormon which is a
broadway play by the south park guys
and yet kind of even though we have
these biases
it is kind of incredible over and over
you see really really strong patterns
despite that
and kind of the the data can kind of get
over these other
these other issues and really see the
predominant use of a search and really
reveal clear patterns
and i think one of the things that uh is
very very clear when you start
just thinking about intuition or playing
through
looking through the data or a lot of
other reasons is there's kind of this
big advantage of google search data and
that's this issue of social desirability
bias
so people will lie to surveys if you ask
them or mislead surveys they don't
really have an incentive to tell the
truth uh
so if you ask people how do we know
people lie well sometimes you can
compare it to the ground truth
so you ask people are you gonna vote in
the election or even immediately after
the election
uh did you vote and something like you
know 80
of the country will say sure i just i
voted you know a week ago they don't
want to admit that they didn't vote and
we actually
you know we have administrative records
we know how many people voted and 80
of americans did not vote you know
something like 50 of people who don't
vote
are going to tell a survey they vote uh
so when you think about that you kind of
have big issues with uh
with surveys and in the in in you're not
getting the honesty well
google is kind of like this ideal uh
platform for getting honest answers
so the way that you get honest answers
the best chances we have even with
surveys
is have people alone and online you tend
to be a lot more honest you're not
talking to someone
and then google takes it a step further
you're not really in a survey
you actually have an incentive like to
look something up uh
you really want to tell the truth and
want to say say wait uh tell the truth
and again of course
you know the private implications here
obviously this data has to be anonymous
and aggregate if we're going to be
uh using data on people uh on these
sensitive topics
but i think that's a real advantage of
google searches
so this first study i did is uh so after
the election if you remember the 2008
presidential election one of the issues
was
uh did obama would race play a role in
obama's
election uh you know the first
african-american candidate ever
it was a big question and if you go back
actually the stories
immediately after the election there
were stories like gallup
gallup calling race not important to
voters and you know something like they
had surveyed every voter and you know 99
plus percent of voters said that race
was not a factor in their vote
uh so uh you know that that and that and
then but this kind of an area
if you think what is an area where
people might not want to admit something
this is kind of one of the areas this is
a sensitive area
in uh american culture today
so what i did is i measured uh racist
search rates in
2004 from 2004 2007 and 200 media
markets in the united states
so excuse i have to use kind of strident
language for this part of the talk if
you can think what is a racist
search so i just did the very simplest
thing i did
uh what percent of google searches
include the racist word
which uh if you actually include
you look at the searches about 20
of these searches are for uh jokes and
you look at the returns you kind of see
very very racist searches and it's a
surprisingly common search it's about
seven million searches in the united
states uh every year with the term
uh you know about as common as like
searches for migraine or economist
uh very common kind of things that are
not uh rare searches
by any struts imagination and you
actually can get kind of a map
this is for media markets again
anonymous aggregate data this is where
it searched more frequently in
uh you know places like west virginia
western ohio
uh east eastern western pennsylvania
eastern ohio southern mississippi
louisiana
actually kind of a surprising map in
some ways you if you if you had asked me
where is racism highest in the united
states i would have said it south versus
north
and when you actually look at this map
it's more like east versus west in some
sense like lots pockets like upstate new
york you know pennsylvania ohio
are higher on racism and appalachia is a
lot higher than kind of
south uh so it's it's it's it's an
interesting map right off the bat this
isn't uh
there's also a search there's also a
word that ends in a
that is used in rap songs if you use
look at that it's a very different map
and that's uh
that's so a lot of people think well
isn't that just a wrap word wouldn't
that be why people are searching it but
that's not it
i don't want to derail your talk but it
seems there's at least three dimensions
there's shades of color there's
distortion of size
and there's clearly lines that mark off
governmental areas or something yeah i'm
sorry this
this is i keep on meaning to change this
map and keep on procrastinating on that
uh it should it should be a nicer map
the these are media markets so they're
basically
defined by nielsen for advertising
purposes it's groups of counties
uh there's a couple confusing things uh
white
is i don't have data on us they're like
a few very white things
darker is darker red is more is higher
search volume search rates
and lighter red is lower search rates
and
yeah i apologize uh yeah i should have
boundaries and stuff uh which should
probably make this a little clearer but
uh it's normalized by google searches
which is probably better than
normalizing by population so uh it's
percent of google searches
i'm sorry because there's the yahoo
versus google
search density map which is different
too right so i mean that's why you'd
want to do
uh normalized by google searches not
normalized by population right
so if you normalize my population you
might be biased by some areas use google
less or even just use the internet less
so
but you can also do a lot of controls
for stuff it's it's pretty
it's pretty clear that uh these are the
areas so well how are we gonna use this
to calculate
uh how much racism cost obama uh so what
i do is i
uh so i compared we can compare we don't
have uh
so obama was ran in 2008 in 2004
john kerry ran a white candidate so the
simplest thing and there are lots of
more
advanced things i do is just compare how
did obama do to carry
what was kind of the difference in the
vote total and of course on average
obama did better than carrie obama won
kerry lost
but you can see in places where there's
low racially charged search rate
obama does about eight or nine
percentage points
better than kerry and places with the
highest racially charged search rate
obama actually does worse than kerry and
this is from social science perspective
i mean you guys might be i don't know in
computer science electrical engineering
you probably have like
very strong relationships and social
science things are very noisy
this is a strong relationship from
social science perspective and then you
do things well is there some other
reason that obama does worse than carry
in areas with high racially charged
search rates you start controlling for
other variables you control for
education levels you control for racial
uh demographics you control for a lot of
other things and
basically this remains a very very
strong predictor and robust relationship
uh there there's also some more advanced
uh
things you can do so one thing we also i
also looked at is i
originally wrote this paper in 2011 but
then 2012 we had this other election
uh so you can compare obama minus obama
and they're kind of like
you can kind of think that if this was
spurious then maybe this this
relationship would continue
or like it would regression to the mean
but if you do obama
minus obama it's flat with respect to
racially charged search rate which i
think
is also convincing another thing i do is
i compare house voting over this time
period
and senate voting and you don't see any
relationship so
democrats weren't like losing support in
areas with high racially charged search
rate over this period
so what this uh i think shows me is that
uh basically racism cost obama a lot of
the vote
i think about three to five percent of
the vote in both the 2008 and 2012
election and this is significantly
higher than you would see in a survey
uh which tend to say that obama lost
only about one to two percent of the
vote
and again i think this really does to
hammer home this point show the power of
google searches
uh where you know the if you ask people
uh
oh a significant percentage of people
who probably were
unfortunately moved by racism against
supporting obama
uh would not say that they that that
this was a motivation
so are there any questions on this study
before i move on to
other ones
uh so another thing that's i think very
useful for google searches and it's also
kind of similarly motivated so i talked
about how people
tend to mislead about voting they say
they're going to vote even when they
actually have no intention to vote or or
they might think they're going to vote
but they
they actually are in so i wanted to see
can we predict
who's going to vote based on google
searches
and the motivation for this is whether
when you're actually going to vote you
actually might have to look up
information you might have to look up
where to vote or how to vote or
register to vote or early vote or lots
of other things
so i simply just measured searches for
vote
in october of an election year compared
to four years earlier
and then i wanted to see if if searches
for vote
have gone up in an area does that
predict the turnout's going to go
up in that area as well
and what do you find that yes there's a
strong relationship that
areas of the country that search for
vote a lot in october
tend to increase their turnout so
you can predict turnout through this
vote search
this is comparing the google vote
searches in 2008
in 2004 and 2008 so the presidential
election
and then this is trying to predict
turnout in the midterm election it's an
even stronger relationship
so in the midterm election turnout's a
big issue a lot of people don't vote in
midterm elections
but basically what this is saying is
that if google vote searches are high in
october in a place
uh before a midterm election or higher
than they were four years ago you should
expect turnout to go up
uh one of the things that's kind of
surprising here is that if you look at
when
voting is is uh when when these searches
have the most predictive power
it tends to be like early to mid october
i would have guessed it would be like
last second vote but
that's kind of it's kind of interesting
i want to guess that people see
it seems like people uh make their
decisions a lot earlier uh
of whether or not they're gonna vote uh
and then i also predicted uh this is the
2008-2012 election this was a little bit
complicated by
hurricane sandy which actually i meant
to give this talk
i was invited to give this talk but
dennis allison uh
before but i i actually couldn't get
this talk because of hurricane
sandy it also kind of messed up my
analysis uh which is
but which is kind of interesting but uh
some of the outliers are due to
hurricane sandy but it's still
a pretty good predictive power so uh
i think in general uh this is really a
good use of search data as prediction
so a lot of times you might have kind of
read about a google flu
and that's kind of similarly motivated
that it takes a while to get the
information
on when people on from the government
sources on flu
and uh you can by seeing like people
search flu symptoms
or cough fever you can actually beat
those
by a few days so this is kind of an
exciting area because the google search
data we get
basically the next day whereas
government sources or other sources
might take uh you know a few weeks or
even
in some cases months or years do you
expect the same thing with regard to
ebola
yeah so ebola is kind of interesting
what google flu is actually interesting
for a number of reasons so
you might have also seen that google flu
kind of fell apart
it people are really excited that you
could predict uh
the flu with google searches and then
about a year ago there were a lot of
news stories about a flu
epidemic that didn't come true and
because of the news stories people were
searching for it and it kind of became
self-fulfilling
and google really overestimated how much
flu there was
so that's that's interesting i think
ebola would run into a similar problem
possibly where
a lot of the searches are for news
stories uh about ebola so the question
is can you see uh
can you can you kind of cut between that
i think it's it's kind of interesting
it's
i've kind of found that using google
searches tends to require like more
creativity than usual data sources
because survey you kind of know what to
do you ask people do you have ebola or
do you have this uh
kind of going through the search data
and figure out what search suggests that
someone has
ebola is not a simple thing to do
and uh it you always kind of run into
into
issues and you know and wording i mean
the other thing is we're trying to you
know
predict unemployment and we had all
these great searches that predicted
unemployment
and then steve jobs died and a lot of
our searches were related to jobs
and everyone says no unemployment
everyone's looking for work all of a
sudden no it's steve
steve jobs died so uh you run into kind
of all kinds of issues
uh it's it's it's not a perfect data set
by any stretch of imagination but i
think the advantages
are very strong that it's worth thinking
through those issues and think about how
you can deal with them
can you take random samples of the word
out of the
queries that have jobs in them are you
allowed to do that
uh yeah so what do you mean random
samples
a random sample there's 89 000 curries
with the word
jobs in it show me a random one
that allows me to to estimate these
things
uh you mean a random one to see like
what percent of them have different
words
uh i don't think you can do that you can
kind of play around and figure out like
what percent
have a certain type of george or words
or what percent have steve in them
or stuff like that but you can't just
get there are a lot of as you can
imagine privacy
a concern so uh it's it's it's not
simple but
it could be uh it could be another thing
that
like people google flu are talking about
is maybe what we can do and this i
thought was really interesting is let's
say you do a search for like flu
symptoms
let's give you a survey right after you
made that and say do you or your family
member have flu
and then you can see over time is that
relationship changing so let's say all
of a sudden news stories
go like become the big reason that
people are searching for flu symptoms
then the percent of surveyed people who
say that flu goes way down
and right away we'll see oh no our
relationship doesn't work anymore
we got to change the model so i thought
that was really that's really promising
i think in general
uh we're working a lot on actually
at google some connecting surveys
to search data anonymous and aggregate
but i think that's gonna be really
powerful
uh in the future is is like try to take
the advantages of surveys that we're
actually asking a question
and like we know what we're looking for
but try to connect them to the
advantages of searches which are like
they're
you know they're big samples and in
small geographic areas and over time
but again like you know at the
geographic level so it's anonymous and
aggregate
are you attempting to build trained
correlators
these basic indicators for uh the
lexicon of search terms to correlate
against a trend
based on ground group yeah so that's
what google flew
was initially and again it's it's so
there are a few there are there there
are a few complications here so so
there's a question like
uh ground truth is is is one issue so
it's great when you have ground truth
that's a good thing for prediction
uh it's also interesting when you don't
have ground truth like ebola
or like uh voting or like racism and i
think uh
you know i don't want to give up in
those areas because i think there is a
lot of power but it kind of becomes a
more interesting like more difficult
question well
well we don't have any ground truth well
what do we but we still think there's
there's information here what do we do
but there's a tool that you might have
or may not have seen that's called
google correlate
which is basically uh you put any time
series or state
variation or state variation data set
into google correlate
and it'll tell you the search terms that
correlate highest with that like the 100
search terms that correlate highest with
that and then what we found is actually
doing that and then using
a machine learning approach to try to
pick between them
is actually pretty powerful so first you
kind of limit the space and then you use
like machine learning to try to
try to predict that but i think you're
right
i think voting like the voting exam is a
little hard because we have so few
examples you have an election every four
years
but if you have something that happens
like every week and you have you know
you know thousands of observations to
predict from then using some of these
machine learning
uh techniques and cross-validation
everything to try to pick your terms
is powerful i think uh but i definitely
think that one of the issues you're
always going to run into
is changes in search behavior that
people are going to start
you know uh like you have something like
looking for a job
and that's a great predictor of
unemployment and then someone writes a
rap song called looking for a job
and looking and everyone starts looking
for a job and you're and
you don't you're no longer predicting
unemployment so it's like it's it's a
lot of like really interesting
sometimes uh humorous issues but it's
kind of like well how do you how do you
deal with them and it might be like
connecting surveys or something with it
or
or somehow kind of training a model to
to somehow be able to pick that that the
relationship is now changing
also deal with the lead lag estimation
so not only the correlation strength but
if there are any phase delays is there
anyway
yes you can do like a week you can push
it back a week or push it forward a week
uh we're also finding though that
there's some issues with uh seasonality
becomes a big issue
so it doesn't do timely no
right not yeah we're kind of trying it's
not using spectral methods
no so we're trying to get we're trying
to like uh kind of change that to make
it more advanced it was kind of like a
this was kind of the first attempt and
it is pretty cool uh but
we do want to do more advanced things
and and and and some of these things
you're talking about so yeah
when you say search terms do you mean
that you can you
i mean one example is
is it both the word things can i say i
have the flu
what are flu cures yes that's that's
more interesting than
news about the flu which is you know the
query itself
yeah so uh yeah so you can do any query
like that you can do
more advanced queries i think uh you
know those those
tend to be rarer like i think even
people with the flu they tend to
probably not
search like i have the flu so so so you
lose some sick you lose some signal but
you lose some noise as well so it's kind
of like
it's kind of a trade-off uh i think the
more the future models
you know it might be that we had some
wrong things but a lot of things like
that you'd think that people like flu
symptoms
you know you think that's a pretty good
one but it seemed to be like driven by
news as well
so
uh not in the initial model that's
another thing in the future model that
might be
that might be better it also gets to
like so it's kind of
it's kind of interesting also that uh
initially when the model fell apart
uh or i don't say felt part it you know
the first model and
i think you know as probably we all know
first models
you know it's good to have first models
and then iterate from there so uh so i
think you know
we're trying to it's not trying to
publish that well
it's just not time to publish yeah so uh
so uh
i think one of the things that oh
uh i've lost my train of thought
uh yeah so flu symptoms
result click no i wasn't gonna say that
uh
yeah maybe now we're gonna add clicks uh
oh so yeah so after it happened
there becomes like they become at some
point existential questions because
people say
well how do we know the ground truth is
right maybe the google searches are
right
maybe if someone types i have the flu
but doesn't go to a doctor
or you know it doesn't get recorded by
the doctor then you know
at some point it's not clear it's not
always clear that the
i think uh you know people because
google searches are new they tend to
want to see it be the ground truth or
match your ground truth
but some of these ground truths when you
see how the sausage is made it's always
there are some a lot of assumptions and
a lot of things that don't always uh
totally totally pan out
so
so then uh the final one is um
child maltreatment and uh so there's a
question of whether
what happens to child maltreatment when
economic
conditions go right this is basically
child abuse so what happens
how does child abuse respond to economic
hardship
so you can see is you know the great
recession basically some parts of the
country nevada arizona
had big increases on employment and some
parts of the country north dakota alaska
were largely unaffected
by the economic condition so did child
maltreatment rise or fall
in the places that were hard hit by the
recession and when you actually look at
the official data
you see that it goes down in places
where unemployment goes up which is
surprising you would have thought
that unemployment goes up you know
people are depressed
a lot of alcohol consumption like a lot
of uh
you know a lot a lot of trouble hardship
stress is going to increase at
childhood treatment it actually says it
goes down well what i think actually
happened
i'm going to show you using google
searches and other forces is it didn't
go down people just stopped reporting it
for various reasons
and actually you see stories that
basically the social services were cut a
lot of times you're getting like stuck
online
you couldn't get through to people and
you couldn't actually report it
also a lot of teachers and uh first
responders were
they lost their job so they were maybe a
little a little more overwhelmed and you
can think of some other reasons
so the first clue that this isn't really
right that this is saying that in places
where unemployment
goes up child maltreatment actually went
down is you look if instead of all
child abuse cases you look just look at
child fatalities from neglect
and the event the uh these are rarer so
it's not as powerful an indicator
but these kind of have to be reported
you can't if something if a kid
you know something is tragic because the
death happens people are gonna
you know it has to be reported so this
actually is completely the opposite
it goes up but you can see it's kind of
a noisy relationship because it's kind
of sparse data
so the second thing i was thinking is
well you know this is one clue but what
about google searches
there are millions of searches every
year for child abuse and
kind of the way i think of this is this
is almost like a poll without actually
taking a poll where it's like
you know you might see something like
that doesn't look right and you kind of
go look is this child abuse child abuse
signs or something like that
uh whether or not you actually go
through and report it
so that's kind of one way uh we can look
at it
and you see that actually uh it's just
like the fatality data but actually this
is a lot stronger data because it's a
lot bigger samples
as it goes way up in places that were
uh hit by the recession so i think and i
kind of looked at the data the other way
what actually happened
is really a lot sadder than what we
thought happened is instead of we
thought the recession the official data
says no the recession
child abuse went down what actually
happened is it went off but people
just you know because of these budget
cuts and some other reasons
people uh stop reporting it
and then there's also really i mean this
kind of almost getting to yours like you
actually search something there's
actually really tragic and this is sad
obviously like really sad
but actually these are a lot rarer with
people actually kids actually do search
you know dad hit me or mom or mom hit me
or you know
that beat me when you actually do search
like this these like were going down
right until the recession and then right
when the session clicks
hits like these types of searches start
going up so you actually see kids
like it's really sad like the contrast
the kids are actually searching things
like this and you're actually seeing the
official data that the reports them are
going down
so which all this anonymous aggregates
norway has an ombudsman for children
okay
and it's obvious that this data we
do need ground truth with respect to
this particular data
and misestimation of the data which is
to say
could have its own consequences is there
a possibility that
google could initiate even though it's
not an official
governmental office an ombudsman for
children so that you can get this data
yeah so uh so after i did this i talked
some people within google and also at uh
at child maltreatment clinics and
they're kind of like you know what can
we do and
and i kind of also don't wanna be like
this is a first model i don't want to be
like but like also it's such an
important issue that's like
you know like i think we're also talking
about you know i don't think we want to
just say this is child mouth treatment
index and say like
here's a black box and we say it like
we're more interested in like here are
the types of searches and then
researchers
can kind of build their models off of
that so it might not be like google
internally is gonna say
here's what's happening to chil you know
to children but actually like if we can
give this data to scientists and
researchers
and child clinics they can say hey hey
you know
what's going on and like so i talked to
a lot of child about treatment
clinics and you know there are lots of
things like even you know just like the
geographic breakdown like where
incidents are highest like that they
don't really know so there are lots of
things that
like i was kind of surprised such an
important issue that there are lots of
things we don't know about it
or that this is kind of an important
area it's like
uh yeah i think that's like that's right
that's where i'm target i think uh
i think it's yeah i think like it's
really you do kind of run into these
things where they are so important that
you do want to say like how can we
we don't want to just like be like a
black box and say like hey hey this but
how can we make sure that we
facilitating that make sure that people
know
that uh that that things are happening
is google like runs into all these
issues because of such a big service
like you know these moral questions
there was uh you know we don't like to
say
you know google doesn't like obviously
to play around with like searches you
want
an algorithm and whatever happens
happens uh but then like
but then searches for suicide like
someone said wait like if someone's
searching for
something like suicide like google's got
to step in someplace here so we realized
that we could put
a phone like a number for the suicide
hotline like right on top of
of uh of the search results so people
can say so people can see that right
away if they're in a crisis so like
they're
and i think that's another one where you
might say well maybe what we should have
here is not just
like these answers from yahoo answers or
something or maybe we should have like
something that kids can learn what
they're supposed to like really
more official policy in a situation like
this because you know a lot of these
kids you know they're 13 14 years old
they don't really know
uh what necessarily and do we want to
leave it to like yahoo answers and
whatever
for something like this or some you know
some
child services we're also talking about
uh potentially
like uh potentially like buying ads and
stuff where they kind of explain
like to kids uh kind of in situations
like this you know and again this is
rare thankfully
these types of searches although part of
the reason for that is because very
young kids
don't use computers don't use google so
it's only kind of
uh you know above a certain age where
you're going to have uh
this as being an indicator but i think
definitely uh
moral issues are there but i think we
also want to you know i think
i don't speak for google but i think uh
you know researchers
can use this data themselves and
hopefully you know making this data as
public as possible so that people can
kind of
you know to do their own models and and
do their own advanced models and kind of
try to
make sense of some of these issues
because we do you know i i definitely
think
that there are a lot of important things
here there's uh you know so
it's kind of amazing like and i feel
like this is because of my grad school
background but it's like there's just so
many things that are poorly measured i
mean just crime in general forget about
you know like we don't really know you
know these crime data they kind of come
out and you know the fact is first of
all a lot of people aren't reporting
them to police
second of all police are sometimes if
you watch the wire
police sometimes are playing around with
these numbers a little bit
so the fact that you know google
searches when you think about it might
have some
some really other useful information on
crime in areas
or even if you you trust the data just
police might get better information
about
uh you know different areas uh where
crime is highest
i'm a little concerned by the spread of
the point clouds that are surrounding
your
the lines you're fitting which is to say
i mean we could say
sociologists have poor signal to noise
ratio
but i mean i i'm pretty worried by what
i'm seeing in terms of the figures that
you've put up
uh yeah i think it depends it depends on
the question too i mean these are areas
where like
i mean i i think from sociology or
economics if you get a t stat of three
on a 50
sample uh that's pretty big uh
this is not by any means like rare for
economists there's a lot of things that
go on
uh in these situations
what that's not actually a
recommendation
it's good compared to economists
uh yeah so i mean that that is a little
bit of a field issue
i think it also depends on the it
depends on the particular question so if
you do something like
searches for unemployment office and
compare that to unemployment rate
you're going to see a very very strong
relationship like uh
way stronger than this if you do you
know uh the
the the first ones i start with like the
searches for jewish and searches for
uh jewish popul the jewish population
you're gonna see an r squared of about
point eight eight
uh so so that would be stronger than
this uh
yeah as far as like as far as i mean i
think
you know i i don't think like in
in like the social sciences we don't
really see you know if you're doing like
a question that's kind of like
difficult and it might be a lot going on
uh we don't really usually see more than
this like i do do
more things controlling for different
things in the paper and it doesn't
really seem to
change the results but uh yeah i think
that might be a
partly that is a field issue where uh
you know the social sciences isn't used
to r squareds
you know that are that high that's kind
of how it works
yeah are there other questions i'm kind
of finished a little early i think
uh yeah so i guess basically this
what this says is that the official data
says the great recession decreased child
abuse
i think the google data combined with
the mortality data say i think
that actually the great recession
probably increased child abuse
but led to decreased reporting of child
abuse
and
i think my conclusion is that uh
anonymous area google searches excellent
new data for social scientists
and a lot of really interesting issues i
think so i mean this isn't a room with
social scientists so
a lot of what i think computer
scientists are doing are basically
making this data usable for people like
me
who don't really know how to do the
backhand stuff of getting rid of spam
and there are
a million interesting questions behind
the scenes
that are going on to make this data at
all uh useful for someone like me
uh i mean tried uh trying to
predict actual individual elections at
the moment
yeah i i check almost every day what the
senate
races are if there was something up on
google
i'd factor that into so that's
so yeah so so right when i did this
everyone's like set this most poi
why are you predicting turnout can you
predict the election like you have
google searches
uh so so it's complicated
i have looked into it uh it's
so there's a complication which is if
you talk about so sorry the presidential
election i'll get to senate in a bit
so start with the presidential election
uh so like 90 percent of presidential
elections
are explained by at the state level what
happened four years
earlier so it's a little hard to improve
on that uh
to get much signal the other issue is
that we've only had so many presidential
elections with google searches
that you really risk fitting the signal
to the
uh you know fitting your model and
cheating a little bit so you really want
to somehow have out of sample tests and
building models
so basically the first thing everyone's
just like well dude searches for obama
predict
if obama searched more than romney does
that mean
you know obama's gonna do better than
romney in a state and that really
doesn't pan out uh there are too many
negative searches about
that include the word obama uh there are
kind of some interesting things that do
have predictive power although like the
r square is like 0.6 so it's not as high
as as
poles and it's kind of like not that
great in impact but they're kind of
interesting
so if you look at uh if you look at
searches for
obama romney versus romney obama
places that search obama romney and go
obama and you search romney obama you go
romney
so it's like yeah you know you're
looking for the obama romney polls
you're probably an obama supporter if
that's how you call the kind of
if that's how you kind of consider the
election so that was kind of interesting
the other one that was really
interesting is if you look at uh
obama jokes searches for search rates
for obama jokes that almost perfectly
predicts
search uh votes for romney so basically
like
uh if you if if you're joking about
someone you probably don't like them
and i was saying this kind of goes like
things that you follow like instead of i
was trying to get google instead of a
favorability index we'd have a joke
ability index
so if you're joking about the more
you're joking about a candidate
you're not going to be able to support
them and then i think
for the senate so so the midterm
elections for the senate elections
uh one thing i didn't point out is that
you actually can have predictive power
just from turnout
so it turns out that democrats depend on
turnout way more than republicans
republicans
kind of vote uh in pretty consistent
numbers regardless the election but
democrats
they're kind of like younger and a
little more fickle maybe they're kind of
maybe maybe not some years yes some
years no so if you actually look at
areas where turnout's going to be high
you can expect the senate democrats can
actually do better than the polls do and
i showed that so
uh so that is one area where you can
just use the turnout to say they're
going to do better
and one thing i haven't tried that i
think might have potential is if you
look at senate candidates or
particularly house candidates
a lot of the issue is name favorability
people just literally don't know the
candidate
if they know the candidate that's
probably a pretty good sign so it might
be interesting if you do like
you know we have 300 whatever house
races i want to check if you can
actually predict
how the house candidates are going to do
just based on whether people are
searching or googling for
them so that might actually do better
than the obama romney because everyone
knows obama everyone knows romney
kind of you're searching uh you might be
searching you know there's kind of
different
uh motivations but so it's complicated i
think the bigger complication is
honestly just we don't have enough
elections that you test like
10 hypotheses one's going to come true
but it's probably just going to be noise
so the more elections we have we
probably can say hey this really
is predictive and this really isn't
predictive
um it seems to me that a lot of
the stuff that you read is based on
scientific nonsense example
racial classification there was
no basis for racial classification it
was made up
several hundred years ago by europeans
in order to justify uh colonizing
the rest of the world they started out
with the fantasy that europe
is a continent which it is there is one
called eurasia
but they pretended it was a continent
and therefore the people were different
from the rest of the world and uh
this fantasy has been accepted by our
media
every day we get statistics in the
number of blacks
whites asian and so forth
in various places and all of that
is based on fantasy classifications
for example um
well first of all what do you do with
mixed races
most people classify obama as black even
those
have duration um
and there's all these statistics that we
get
that are pure assets they arise in two
ways
sometimes people are asked to classify
themselves and they
make up a fantasy of some sort
and do that but more often somebody
looks at them
and classifies them
and that is pure nonsense
we're all mixtures of ancient tribes
and most europeans of course are part
all europeans are part neanderthal i'm
proud that i'm
2.6 according to my dna
but the rest it could all be
put on a scientific basis based on dna
analysis
as i pointed out in an article 25 years
ago
but nobody wants to do that instead
we keep making up statistics and
publishing them
as if they meant suffering they don't
this is sad there's no ground truth
in racial classification and yet
the newspapers aren't followed is that
really the point
i mean you say that that obama is
only half black but so it's wrong to
call them a lot but
if the issue is you're trying to study
racism effects
and if 100 of the country sees him as
being black or at least not white
i mean what what you're researching is
correlations between
public perception of different things
yeah i mean i don't know is this related
to like
my research is generally this generally
this is a fantasy that our whole society
indulges
in and i mean i think like
i think in general i agree with you that
like a lot of statistics that
we take for face value you see how the
sausage is made and there are a lot of
questions
that are worth asking for a lot of them
uh yeah i'm hoping that a lot of new
data sources do improve on that
i'm not an expert on this racial stuff
classification stuff so i don't really
know
i mean racial issues you also run into
there's so much uh
for for historical reasons there's so
much like
sensitivity around them for obvious
reasons so like
you know like genetics and race i think
is uh
pretty people stay away from that but
for you know like the question is do we
really want to know that or
so you're running into the hidden power
agenda
variable in social sciences in other
words people create
uh sets of words and sophistry
to legitimize a particular point of view
so what do you do when you get powerful
tools that had
headlong into this land of controversy
yeah i think you try to be careful and
you know i mean i think to say that that
statistics are dangerous
like uh yeah i i'd agree with that
uh i don't know if there's a there's an
easy answer i feel like you know
i'm trying to be careful in my research
and not really you know i probably have
subtle biases i'm sure
that play into the things that i'm that
that i'm saying or the research
results or the questions that i ask so
yeah those are kind of broad questions i
don't really have a great answer but
yeah
interesting topics with a lot of
potential but
i get the sense that at this stage
you're sort of calibrating to what
extent
can these tools actually be used and how
reliable are they
there's a there's almost a
self-fulfilling prophecy type thing that
when you
did an initial search trying to
correlate child abuse with unemployment
the results were wrong and so you looked
at it more carefully
and found some way of framing the search
in such a way that it came out with the
results you were expecting
so this that seems like a yeah so
i agree that this is something i didn't
get too much into so
i think the most difficult issue with
using google searches is that there are
so many potential searches they can just
cherry pick
and you find the one that gives you
exactly what you want i mean you learn
from that experience perhaps
yeah so the thing so the thing that i
try to do to avoid cherry picking
is i start with kind of like the word
and i kind of feel like if you start
with the word and you start with
okay like like i could have said if i
came to you and said hey i found like
one like racist thing it's like like
i do not like african people or
something like that was the search
and then it was like this proves against
obama and you probably say well
what about i don't like african-american
people i don't like black people or like
there are a million other searches like
how did you
determine that that was the one whereas
if you start with kind of this big
thing that searched more than everything
else and there's kind of the word
i think there's a little bit i think uh
and i'm arguing that there's a lot
less concern for that uh i i
i i take that this is a big issue
and that a lot of the research quite
frankly that i've seen with google
searches i think
is guilty of this issue uh and says you
know we can predict the stock market by
these 10 words and it's kind of like
well how did you how did you choose
those 10 words
is this just noise uh i think so
yeah i mean that that i think i think
the
i think it's the main issue google
searches and the approach i take is
taking the most
the most salient word i think there are
other approaches like if you have uh
if you have a ground truth you can
actually like use an in sample
prediction and say
what ones correlate the highest and then
use an outer sample prediction so that's
kind of another way to calibrate
yourself
uh yeah those are i think the other i
think uh you know they're also like
let's say so so you start with like the
most salient one then you say well what
happens if you add like the second one
or add the third one or add the fourth
one doesn't change
uh i think is the other way to deal with
it what about using semantic
networks as the as the basis as opposed
to word frequency
in other words at a certain point
one wants to correlate against meaning
and so it makes sense to understand
phrase and and so you're busy trying to
pick words
natural language programming is quickly
advancing from
you know word count frequency and
proximity to
operations on semantic graphs and
correlations of semantic graphs
not that i understand this science but
google turns out to be on the front
the leading edge of this yeah so i
totally agree that this is like
an exciting area and texture just
basically text as data
this kind of just the broader point of
texas data which runs into this issue
of how you deal with it uh this is kind
of done before some of those tools were
advanced i think and
there are other issues they didn't get
to so one of these issues you get is
that
like the n word is searched so much more
than any other racist thing
that if you add anything else to it you
basically have the same measure because
it's just like
if you had anything else that's racist
you still have the same measure so it's
kind of like
this one it doesn't matter unless you
don't include that word uh so
uh so you know sometimes you're in less
visit sometimes you're not in that
situation sometimes you have
you know 50 choices and they might be
equally searched and then maybe you need
some of these tools to say
well which ones do we include but i
think you know cherry picking is always
an issue in social science i think
cherry picking is more of an issue uh
with google searches because you have
these you know so many potential
searches to choose from
the cherry picking might even be
generous
in a way um i'm not i hadn't heard the
google flu thing before i
presume that has something to do with
the fact that you're assuming
flu frequency somehow correlates with
the searches for the word flu
in the case of the ebola virus
100 of the people of ebola are located
in one precinct in texas right now
so any correlation between that word and
anything else would be false
there's so there are so few people with
ebola the
people looking for it or not in any way
influenced by the number of people that
have it in the country
yeah uh i think that's right i think
like
i think yeah i i just always want to get
back to one thing you said is like kind
of
you look for it seems like like a lot of
chris when i get my research is this
seems all very obvious or like you found
that
well we all know we all suspect that in
a recession child view is going to go up
and it actually went down
so you're like show that it went up i
think part of the reason is because
these tools are not that advanced but if
you say something like new and explosive
and you're like hey ebola is really high
in vermont or something like that
and you know you say something kind of
like you know so some of this
is at the early stage we're kind of just
showing that this data actually is
showing things we kind of already knew
uh but you know maybe from that we can
start saying well one of these areas we
really don't know and have no idea
what tools should we use to try to
answer these questions one of the sort
of surprising things is
to me is that how cute
actually let's say they're different how
do you get more ground through simple
you mentioned
the possibility that alcohol might have
something to do with child use
that's that's a measurable ground truth
because you can look at
tax receipts for alpha taxes um
and you're in google so shouldn't you
have a lot of ground truths just sort of
laying around
that you should could be popping in uh
yeah i mean i think well just social
scientists in general i don't think
but social science at google is not
social science in general
yeah you should have a lot more data
just sit around just because that's what
you do
uh yeah so i mean there are also like
private
issues i i don't i don't yeah i think
there's no privacy
yeah there's there shouldn't be uh yeah
so i think
there's a ton of statistics in the world
and you're no longer
a grad student trying to do five things
using spss
you've got the google plus in some sense
working for you
yeah so he's trying to like put
everything together and so
is google licensing wool from status
sets no i don't think
it's not a so street uh sorry
his data sets are like i think publicly
available or he's purchasing them so
i think so but but yeah i think
i think in general just forget google
like yeah like google's a big company
like
uh just in general like there's data
that's exploding all over the place
uh and it's kind of like a really
exciting time to be a social scientist
and also kind of a scary time because
like all these
all these issues are talking about like
cherry picking and stuff like that we
kind of don't really know what we're
doing with all this data
but it's like exploding at a rate that
we've never really seen before
uh with all these new like basically you
know online sources or digital sources
where like
uh you know things are recorded you know
anonymous and aggregate data so
it sounds like the curse of
dimensionality is basically eating you
alive
in other words in the end you actually
aren't going to be able to figure these
things out
when you realize how many degrees of
freedom in the measurement are possible
and the small number that you are
actually entertaining yeah i don't i
don't
i don't think that's true i think that's
i think that uh
i mean i think the things that i've
shown i'm pretty confident that are
truly there in the data i think that
i think there's also uh you know when
you're
when you're trying to predict something
and you have you know a thousand three
thousand observations you actually will
see with like google correlate
that the things that pop up are very
very reasonable and you're not
kind of dying from the curse of
dimensionality uh so
i i i don't think you can't say anything
because that i just think that you have
to be careful
and that i think that a lot of the
things that that
i read i am skeptical of you know when
when they tell you that
i think someone wrote a paper they it
was based on like twitter data
and they said that from from tweets like
if someone has
if there's anxiety three days prior the
stock market's gonna go down
and when you when you read something
like that you're kind of like really
like
you know like how many possibilities are
there include that include anxiety three
months three days before and why should
we expect that at all
uh so i think in those situations
definitely like a healthy amount of
skepticism is necessary
but i definitely don't think that that
uh you know eliminates the possibility
of saying anything
so how many people are there doing this
sort of work and what fraction of the
work for political plans
ah so so so uh
it depends how you define this sort of
work uh
so google trends was like surprisingly
underutilized which is why i wrote my
thesis on it i'm like why isn't
everybody like obsessed with this data
like it seems so awesome
uh but i mean quote-unquote big data in
general and that that's like an issue
that that's like important for social
sciences is kind of that's growing very
very fast
so people are becoming a lot more
interested in some of these digital data
sources uh
to try to learn them and you know yeah
the obama campaign like obviously was
using a lot of these these new tools and
a lot of these huge data sets
uh to try to understand uh you know
political behavior so
i think big data like i think this is
kind of considered big data even though
i only use like 100 observation of 200
observations there's
big data that computer scientists and
electrical engineers turn into small
data for people like me
so it is kind of big data but uh that's
kind of what what people are talking
about that's like
really really hot field work but i think
there's a lot of
it's a lot of just uncertainty it's not
like people don't know exactly what
we're doing
uh or what people should do with these
data sets except that everyone kind of
has an instinct that there is a lot to
learn in here
and i think from the things i've shown
you know people might disagree that
there actually are insights in this data
uh and that i would defend these these
things i found pretty strongly
uh if someone came back if someone
disagreed with the findings
so can you say
you're allowed to or not allowed or
whatever but what what do you see as
being the goal of your department
trying to develop tools that the world
large could use or are you trying to
find
trends that google might use internally
yeah so sorry for the confusion so this
is like
this is basically a talk i was agreed to
give before i even
came to google so this is basically
research i've done outside my time
my my my work at google uh this is not
like
uh google google's work or anything this
is my own word
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know i understand
so
yeah so uh so yeah so so i don't speak i
think
you know i i could just say that i think
people at google
are interested in how social scientists
might use their data i don't think
they're trying to like
create internally like a social science
department or anything because i think
they think like
you know like i think social science is
better when uh
when it's done by the scientific
community and it's you know external and
very like transparent and stuff so i
don't think so all this stuff i've been
showing you is all publicly available
you could just go online like reproduce
all this stuff yourself
uh so i don't i don't think you know i
the work i do at google is really
separate none of this stuff all the
stuff was done before i
got to google and outside google the
work i do for google is really separate
and
uh from this stuff so it's just i think
i have an expertise in this area so
they're kind of like well
you know you understand our data so well
you probably should should work here so
yeah
okay
you